Hello, and welcome back
to "Route 85," our road
trip of knowledge
for iOS developers
where we don't have rest
stops, we have great points.
And part three on
our little series
on opening a link in Chrome iOS.
Now as you recall from last
time-- which you should watch
if you haven't yet--
we were able to open
a link from our app
directly in Google Chrome
and add a button in
Chrome that goes back
to our app using this giant
URL that takes advantage
of the x-callback URL format.
But there's one
little problem here--
it turns out that if you have
a very old version of Chrome,
like you haven't updated
it in over two years,
and you tried to open this
URL, it wouldn't work.
You see, Chrome didn't add
support for the x-callback URL
stack until like
November of 2012.
But because this URL still
begins with the Google Chrome
scheme our UI
applications can open
URL method would evaluate
to "true" or "yes."
It's only once our
old version of Chrome
receives this URL
that it barfs, so we
have no way of knowing whether
or not our version of Chrome
is recent enough to handle
this x-callback URL.
Or do we?
Dun, dun dun.
You see, what the
Google Chrome team did--
which I think is
kind of clever--
is they added a third
URL scheme called
Google Chrome x-callback.
This was added at the same time
that the team added support
for x-callback URL, which means
that you can check and see
if Google Chrome supports
x-callback URL by asking if it
can open a URL that begins
with the Google Chrome
x-callback scheme.
Now if it can't, then
that's OK-- you just
revert back to the
basic Google Chrome URL.
But if it can, then you just
pass in the full URL as is.
So let's go back to
our sample application
here and put this into action.
Here I am back in my
ViewController.m file
and what I'm going
to do here is I'm
going to change my callback URL
so that instead of beginning
with googlechrome-s,
it's going to begin
with googlechrome-x-callback.
I'm running out of space
here, so let's put this
on another line.
Great.
And so now I have three
URLs that I can use.
I've got my callback URL for
modern versions of Chrome,
my basic Chrome URL for
fairly old versions of Chrome,
and my plain old Safari URL.
So now let's go into
my "if" clause here.
So first I'm going
to check and see,
can I open my
fancy callback URL?
If I can, then I know
my version of Chrome
supports the
x-callback URL scheme
and can therefore
handle this URL that
points back to my application.
If it can't, then I'm going to
add another check here and see,
well, at the very
least can you open
the URL that is my Chrome URL?
If so, then I know that I have
a version of Chrome installed,
albeit a fairly old one.
But still, I can have
my UI application,
shared application,
open URL, or Chrome URL.
And otherwise if it can't
open either of those,
I know I don't have
Chrome installed at all
and I will fall
back to use Safari.
So there we go.
If we open this app
again on my device,
we can see that clicking on this
button will bring up Chrome.
And the fact that Chrome has
this back button pointing back
to my app means that we passed
along the x-callback version
of the URL and not
the basic Chrome one.
And that's because I
have a version of Chrome
that is less than two years old.
I actually can't show you this
working on a really old version
of Chrome-- I'm not quite
sure where to get it--
but I guess you'll
just have to trust me
that that would work too.
So this is all fine and
dandy, but I have now
expanded my simple code
to open a URL from one
or two lines to,
like, what-- 12?
And we did a bunch of manual
URL escaping in the process.
So it seems like I probably
want to abstract this logic out
into a separate class
or something, right?
Well as luck would
have it, Google
has already done
the work for us.
So let's take a
look at that next.
So let's go visit the
OpenInChrome GitHub page over
at GitHub.com/Googl
eChrome/OpenInChrome.
Now you can go ahead and grab
these files however you'd like.
You can download the ZIP or
clone the repository locally.
I think I am just going
to grab the ZIP file here.
And then once it's done, I'm
going to open up my ZIP file.
And within here
are the two files
you're going to need--
OpenInChromeController.h
and OpenInChromeController.m.
So I'm just going to
drag these two directly
into my project in Xcode here.
I'm going to say,
yes, let's copy these.
And you can go ahead and check
out these files if you want.
If you've been following these
lessons up until this point,
most of this code should
look pretty familiar to you.
They're just being a little
more robust and a little more
bulletproof than
our sample code.
So go ahead and check these out.
You can check out most
importantly the .h file,
which is the actual public
interface of this class.
You could see that
basically it's a singleton.
We have a nice Boolean,
IsChromeInstalled,
and we can either open a URL in
Chrome or open a URL in Chrome
with a callback URL.
So let's go back to
my ViewController
here and go back to my
"Open In Web Page" method.
And basically, let's
just delete all of this.
All that hard work-- gone.
So I'm going to go ahead
and define two URLs here.
The first is the URL that
I actually want to open.
We'll call it pageToOpen, it'll
be an NSURL, URL with string,
and this can be
just a plain old URL
that opens up www.google.com.
Then let's add a second URL,
which is our callback URL.
And this is going to become
'googleOpenInChromeExample;'.
Again, note the colon
at the end there,
and clearly you should make
this specific to your app.
Now the code to open
this up is much simpler.
First, let me go
ahead and import
my OpenInChromeController.h.
And I'm just going
to add an "if" clause
that says if
OpenInChromeController shared
instance is Chrome-installed--
well, if that's the case, then
let's just open it in Chrome.
And I can do that by calling
the method OpenInChromeCont
rollerSharedInstance.
OpenInChrome-- for
this URL, I'm going
to make it the page to open.
With callback URL, can
be our callback URL.
And create a new tab-- it's
probably not necessary,
so I'll say "No" here.
Format this nicely.
And otherwise, user doesn't
have Chrome installed.
So we'll just fall back to
opening up this link in Safari.
And this is our plain old UI
application/ shared application
open URL method.
And the nice thing here is
that the OpenInChromeController
is doing all the heavy lifting
in converting my ordinary URL
into an x-callback URL with all
that percent escape information
all over the place.
In fact, let's go into
this controller here
and we'll add a little
NSLog statement that
shows what URL it actually
ends up trying to open.
So right here, I'm going to
add a little NSLog that says,
I am attempting to
open-- and we'll
look at our Chrome
URL absolute string.
So we can give this a
try now by running it.
And just like always,
I have a button.
I can click on it,
takes me into Chrome,
and there's a Back button
that once again takes me back
to my application.
And we go back to
our console and we
look at what's been
generated here.
We can see that yes, it has
taken our very simple URL
and converted it into the giant
x-callback URL that is required
to open this in Chrome
with the Back button.
So we'll stop this.
And so now I'm sure you can
see we have some logic that
is really easy to convert to
a more general purpose method.
Now maybe in a real application,
when the user starts up
the app, you can check and see
if they have Chrome installed.
If they do have Google
Chrome installed, then maybe
the first time the
user clicks on a link,
you can bring up an alert
view or an action sheet that
lets them select
their default browser.
Save that information
in NS User Defaults,
remember that choice
in the future.
And then you could write
a simple "open URLs
in preferred browser"
method that takes a URL
and makes the appropriate
call to open it.
And there you go.
I now have an
application that opens up
links in the user's browser of
choice, whatever it might be.
And in case you're wondering,
do extensions in iOS 8
make this entire
system obsolete?
The answer would
appear to be no.
iOS 8 does support a number
of actions with extensions.
And I suspect that there are
some use cases of URL schemes
that could now be better
handled by extensions.
However, opening up a web page
isn't currently one of them.
So now at this point,
we're basically
done with our main
goal of showing you
how to open up a link
in Chrome on iOS,
but we can still have
a little more fun
with that x-callback
URL and see how
we can take
advantage of the link
that Chrome is using to send
the user back to our app.
And I'll show you how to
do that in the next lesson.
So stay tuned.
[ROCK MUSIC PLAYING]